[Applause]
Wow a podium and everything hey Leon
Samberg
KTLA congratulations dude thank you so
many people unstirred yourself amongst
them came out after the film was out and
I don't want to use the word apology but
wanted to reframe I think when some
people were saying about do you have
thoughts about that well yeah I think
that look there's a lot of disgusting
behavior in this in this movie I mean
you could see that up on screen but it
was a very much a reflection of this
culture and we wanted this to be a
cautionary tale and and we wanted to
accurately portray this darker nature of
our culture and it was a reaction to
what happened in 2008 we as filmmakers
wanted to you know display this part of
humanity up on screen and the
irresponsibility that came with it so
you know Marty's never been I think a
didactic type of director that explains
their spoon spoon feeds to an audience
what the ramifications of these actions
are he just he goes in there and says
look I'm not going to judge these
characters I'm going to show them for
what they are and purposely didn't cut
away to the victims of this type of
behavior and also you know you have a
protagonist at the end who ultimately
doesn't get his due and proper but that
is also a reflection of reality and
that's what Marty does and that's why
his films in my opinion are timeless
because they're not specific to that
period it's it's it's portraying a part
of humanity and and all its truth and
and and those are the types of films I
want to be involved with so yeah I think
we had to try to put it into the context
of people understanding the type of
movie we wanted to make and that was at
the end of the day very much a
cautionary tale
speaking of the disgusting things on
screen one of your speeches this season
you apologize your parents you know the
things that you did did you watch it
with them did you have a good laugh yeah
that was very much just a little bit of
a joke they they understand that you
know I'm playing a character here and
look all of us really had the attitude
of playing characters that had no moral
compass that gave in to every temptation
possible and were completely consumed by
you know power power and wealth and you
know we kind of looked at it as like a
giant Hieronymus Bosch painting or
something it was just pure debauchery
and we were Roman emperors in the middle
of it and so therefore you know I think
that once he put into that context and
my parents felt the same way was it was
entertaining
right how would you explain why you
alliterative with martin scorsese's
working so well while you're working so
well together it's easy for me I mean I
was inspired by his work he's he's
really the one of the first film makers
as a young man that I became trend
transfixed and completely as an audience
member was enveloped in the
characterization of the people that he
put up on screen and I was his he
inspired my whole generation everybody
that I grew up with is influenced and
completely the biggest fan of his work
and I've learned so much about making
movies and the choices that you make
while making movies film history what
cinema means as an art form to our to
our very culture and I continue to learn
every time I work with him I suppose his
attorney has to do with the fact that we
share similar tastes and I'm willing you
know to do whatever he wants up there on
screen really and I just been very
fortunate that we found material through
the years that we both been attracted to
and I think ultimately we've gained more
and more trust with each other as the
years have gone by and I would I could
only be lucky enough to work with him
again because it's been a huge gift in
my life thank you guys
[Applause]